SHABIH RIZVI: My
name is Shabih Rizvi.
I'm on the Google Play
Business Development Team.
And I get to work with a
lot of great app developers.
And I'll be OK.
Thank you.
And three of those guys
are actually here today.
So I thought it'd be really
nice for you guys see here
from these guys
about what they've
done on Google Play,
what's worked for them,
and then hopefully,
we'll save some time
at the end for some questions.
So with that, Mel,
maybe you could
tell us a little more about
your background, the company
that you guys work for, and
where you guys are based.
MEL KIRK: Hey, everyone.
Mel Kirk.
I work with Zen Studios.
We are based in
Budapest, Hungary.
We have offices here
in northern California.
We're a game developer.
We develop across console,
PC, and mobile and recently,
in the couple years,
heavily into mobile.
And I guess the work we're
best known for Pinball titles
but very recently a game
called Castle Storm,
which we can successfully
used the Google beta
program to help grow user
base prior to launch and then
launch.
So something I'm
really excited about
and happy to talk with
you guys about that today.
SHABIH RIZVI: Introduce
yourself as well.
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL:
Yes, so hey guys.
Brendan here from Soundwave, one
of the founders of Soundwave.
We're based out
of Dublin, Ireland
and we're just
setting up an office
here now in that San Fran,
as well, which we're excited
about.
So Soundwave is a mobile app.
We've got some cool
technology in it
that allows you to identify all
the songs that they're playing
across all the various different
music services and music apps.
So anytime you play a song,
it'll then sync that song
to your Soundwave profile
and then your friends
can find and follow you and see
what music you're listening to.
So you can check out what
your buddies are listening to
on Spotify or YouTube, or
iTunes, or anywhere else.
So we have a team of
10 based in Dublin,
Ireland and we've been using
the community, the G+ community,
and the Alpha Beta, all
that extensively, as well.
So happy to chat
about that, too.
FREDERIC DELLA FAILLE: Hi.
I'm Fred from Frontback.
I'm Belgian and we
just won the game.
Five minutes ago, I guess.
So I have at photo
app called Frontback.
We basically use both
cameras of your phone.
I got this idea that summer and
it sounds really, really stupid
but actually, we
discover along the way
that it's much more than
a photo and a selfie.
It's what you see
and how you feel.
And the selfie's really
about sharing your feelings
through your friends.
I love to say that your
friend doesn't really
care about what
you eat, they want
to see if you are well,
if you look happy.
And we recently
launched on Android.
Thanks to Shabih again,
that's the best thing that
happened to us,
is being connected
with Shabih came to our
office multiple times.
He introduced us to the good
people at Google and so.
Yeah, after-- one thing
that we try to fight
is the [INAUDIBLE], so we
don't try to create buzz.
We released the app without
telling anyone for a week,
just to see the bug, just
to see real user, not just
your mom that really
loves what you do,
having people who
hates what you do.
And so together with Shabih,
that's how we launched.
And we are super focused so.
SHABIH RIZVI: So, Fred I'll
leave it with you for a second.
Could you share a little
bit about the back story
and then there was an
idea that came along.
So, could you share just
like two minutes of--?
FREDERIC DELLA
FAILLE: Yeah, so some.
I was graffiti artist so all
my life is about creativity
and I tried to build
something, a communication
platform on the web to share
multiparty [INAUDIBLE].
And we got traction in a browser
but we raise money with VCs
based on the consumer.
And we had to find
something on the mobile
and we tried not to share
multiple photos where
you can change the colors,
typeface, and personalize
your multiple photos that
you share on social media.
It really didn't
took off as expected.
So we were running out
of money two weeks left
and that's not for the drama,
that's really what happened.
Two weeks left of money, I
should have stopped everything
and raised more money at
that time but I didn't.
And so, I had this simple idea
of this front and back photo
that I share on
Checkthis, which is
the name of the other platform.
And my friends in Belgium say,
"Fred, you look super tired."
Because this is really
what the content was about.
It's not about building
a beautiful app,
it's about having something
that people could actually use.
And now for the first
time, I got the use cases
of these two photos.
So my co-founder came
in Brooklyn last year.
And I told Melvin, we are
going to stop everything.
Don't tell our
investors but I think
we're going to build something.
And we did it in four weeks.
We released this app iOS first.
We released this app and we got
100,000 download in a month.
And so obviously
the investors who
didn't wanted to put more money
were like my new friend again.
And so, yeah.
That's a little bit our story.
SHABIH RIZVI: Great, thank you.
Brendan, one of the things that
I was really happy with you
guys is-- and I've put other
developers in touch with you--
this is about Alpha Beta.
Could you talk a little bit more
about how guys have use that,
how you built your
community, and how
you continue to use that today?
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL:
Yeah, for sure.
And so, before we
launched anything,
we actually started reaching
out to the existing just G+
communities, when we had
literally sketches on paper,
when we had paper prototypes,
when we had anything.
And we just dropping in little
messages into the Android
Design G+ communities and
Android Dev G+ communities
and just getting feedback as if
our product existed before we
even built it.
So we're just in
there, hanging out
in all these different
communities, just saying,
"What do you think
about this type of app?
And what do you think about
these types of designs."
And for every niche area that we
wanted more feedback on, there
was an existing community
inside in G+ with hundreds
of thousands of active people
just crying out for content
to talk and share
about and to critique.
See, we reach out
to those guys and we
started building this really
great following every time
we put up a post.
We get a lot of traction on it.
And we decided from there to
build our own community inside
G+.
We set up a Soundwave
testing community,
invited in all the
kind of the people
that we've been engaged with in
the other existing communities.
We tried to make it exclusive
so that only people that we knew
who were actually going
to actively contribute
could get in.
And then from there,
building on that.
We really-- when the
Alpha Beta Store came out,
we connected that up with
our existing community.
And then everything
that we do, get
through all of that
community first.
These guys are vicious but
in a really positive way.
They find everything, more
than we possibly could.
As a result of that, we
rolled all of our QAs
is pretty much done
by our community.
And they find everything that
we could possibly imagine.
And then from there, after
we have a clean build,
then that's when we
push it live afterwards.
But it's for us-- it's
an invaluable resource.
It's like an extra
couple of hundred people
that we feel like they're
an extra team member.
We talk to them every day, so.
SHABIH RIZVI: Awesome.
Mel, you had mention
that, as well.
It'd be great to get a game
developer's perspective on how
was it, how you guys
set it up, and how
you plan on using
it moving forward.
MEL KIRK: Yeah, absolutely.
We, too, set up with G+, as
terms of people being able
to access the APK,
login to our group.
Coming from a console and PC
background, PR in core games
is very important part
of promoting your game.
So we took a lot of
the same approach.
And we literally
announced the game
and announced the beta
was live at the same time.
And we had a links straight
to the G+ group just made this
an open invitation.
And a lot of the press
actually posted that
and they thought it
was really novel idea.
Early access games have been
taking off on the PC side
so to them, I think, it was an
interesting approach on mobile.
So this first run of
PR coverage actually
generated quite a bit
of just awareness.
And so day one, we were
hoping to get 1,000 people
during the course of the beta.
In day one, we had 1,000 people.
And by day three, we had 3,000.
And then by the time we were
done, we end up with 10,000.
But what was really
great about it
was the amount of data
and feedback that we got.
A lot of times when you
launch your game, your app, it
takes a certain
level of investment
to get your first round of data.
And then you got to analyze
that and you figure out
what the heck is going on in
your game and if you monetizing
and how to optimize.
So we got through all of
that but prior to launch.
And we were able to launch
with a much better game
in our hands.
We knew our players who were
having a hard time in the game,
where they were dropping off.
We knew which
countries were going
to be more prone to advertising.
And so we needed to have
better fill rate for ads
and find better
partners in advertising.
We found out where bugs were.
We have a large QA
team, 25 people on QA.
But this army of 10,000 players
are finding bugs for us.
We were able utilize
word of mouth
and just build a
community around it
and have other people
talking about the game
with their friends.
So, overall a great experience.
We're going to launch
every game this way
on mobile going forward.
There's no question about it.
A lot of potential there.
SHABIH RIZVI: Great, awesome.
Fred, if we could bug you again.
I know your company
focuses a lot on community.
And I think a lot of that
also has to do with growth.
And we were just having a
conversation about-- Fred
and I were talking about in
the early stages of a company,
and as you're first getting
your app into the store,
he was talking about how
important it is to community.
Could you talk a
little bit about what
you think is so important about
that, how you guys have built
your community out, and
what you think about
as you continue to grow that?
FREDERIC DELLA FAILLE:
Thank you, yeah.
I think for us,
community's everything.
Just an example is
most of the employee
actually were poor user.
And that's first,
something very important.
And we have makeup and mask
and costume at the office
because we interact with the
community when there is a body,
we interact.
And so we really focus on a
small number of people who
totally get . it
and who generally--
I never know how to say
this word in English.
Anyway, I'm going to
choose another one.
But people who deeply
love and get it.
And I think, just a
few hundred is enough.
And that's what
we did on Android.
We didn't wanted to have our
friends playing with the beta
just to have this beta.
This upcoming project,
we wanted people
who really want to take photo.
and using it.
And so, all our focus
is on community.
We rent an office, which is a
live-and-walk space so we have
bedrooms and office and we spend
a lot of time with the user.
They stop by and we have
barbecue with the user.
So after this
moment, they really
have something-- they
got a moment with us
and I think that that
makes a difference.
SHABIH RIZVI: Very cool.
Thank you.
Brendan.
Love to hear your thoughts
on community, as well.
So we talked about
the app community,
getting people to test your app.
But you've got a whole other
set of your business, which
is interacting with musicians,
getting fans on board.
Could you talk a little bit
about how you build that out
and maybe some of the
artists that you guys
have worked with over time?
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL:
Yeah, for sure.
I just thought that
was really interesting
that you said that you had
people in the office as well.
Because that's something
that we've done.
We got an open door policy where
once every two weeks, anyone
can just walk in and
hang out with us.
I think people were actually
really kind of surprised
by that because I thought
everybody was doing that,
but they're for sure not.
And so yeah, we have that.
We make a strong effort to have
a physical community, as well
as having the online community.
One thing might be
worth touching on we
actually have a Brand
Ambassador Program which
grew out of our community.
So we had some people that
were in the community,
giving feedback that really
liked what we're doing so much
they asked is there a formal way
that they could get involved.
As a result of that, we now
have 50 brand ambassadors.
50 brand ambassadors
in 50 countries.
And all these guys are actively
doing community outreach,
PR outreach, artist outreach.
And it's how we're actually
on-boarding a lot of artists.
And so musicians
and artists really
like using Soundwave because
when they download it,
when they then listen to
music on Spotify or YouTube
or anywhere else on
iTunes, they're instantly
showing their fans what
they're actually listening to.
And as we started growing in
all these different countries
and we started getting brand
ambassadors in those countries,
they'd start saying
"well, hey why don't you
get this artist on.
I love this guy.
He's huge in Tokyo.
He's huge in Thailand."
And it was actually
through our community
that we started really growing.
So we've done no formal
marketing on Soundwave to date
and yet we're in 190 countries.
That's all just through
the community, just
sharing to other people, and
onboarding local artists,
local PR, local community
ambassadors all around them.
So there's just little
mini hubs everywhere
that are sharing and spreading
the word of Soundwave.
And that's-- we owe our
community 100&% for that.
SHABIH RIZVI: Awesome.
What are some of the
things you guys do
to promote new applications
that you guys have built?
Do you guys do cross
promotions of your games?
How do you guys
think about that?
MEL KIRK: There's a lot
of things that we do.
We also cross promote
with other developers.
Like Vector Unit, they
make a game called Rip Tide
and they're good
friends of ours.
And we just talk to
each other and said
it'd be really nice if we
had a network of developers
that we could get together
with and literally just share
traffic and drive traffic
when a new app is launching.
And so we tried it together
and it was really great.
And we just said "OK, we'll
give you 25,000 clicks."
And so we reciprocated and
we were driving traffic
to each other's games.
It costs you nothing to do.
And if you have friends,
other developers,
I'd highly recommend
working together.
To this date, Zen has not been a
single dime on user acquisition
yet our Pinball titles are
roughly 50 million installs
across iOS and Android.
Castle Storm, we just
launched in early May.
And we're roughly,
we're a few million in.
We're just getting started.
Hearing what these guys are
talking about with community,
in letting people access your
game or your application,
and be open with them,
let them see who you are,
and to have a really
special relationship,
you're going to get a lot
more than you think out
of these people.
And working together with
a development community,
working on your
PR, your message,
finding people who are really
into your game, your app,
and who will talk
about it publicly.
They've got an audience, engage
them on a very personal level
and get people talking.
It goes a long way.
SHABIH RIZVI: Awesome.
Maybe we can keep
things with you
and talk a little bit
about monetization.
What forms of monetization do
you guys use with the games
that you guys have?
What models have you
guys experimented with?
And then, would you have any
recommendations for the group
that's here on how to
figure out monetization?
It'll vary by developer.
MEL KIRK: We've done paid.
We've done a free app
with in-app purchasing.
And just recently, we've
done a free download,
in-app purchasing
plus advertising.
And for us, all
three have worked.
But I got to say, the most
exciting and the most promising
is this hybrid approach
with in-app purchasing
and advertising.
We will essentially
allow you to buy the game
for a certain price, which
turns off ads and gives you
a certain level of virtual
currency on a weekly basis.
And when we introduce
new content,
you do have the ability
to use your currency
but it's probably
not going to be
enough to fully unlock
that new content.
And then ads.
There's incentivized and
there's non-incentivizd.
So I'm getting money for every
user that comes in the game.
And there's no bad user
for me at that point
or no non-monetarizing
user which
I know everyone's always
looking for quality users.
I say that really
look at that approach.
There's certain countries,
like Russia, for example,
they don't spend very
much money at all on IAPs
but they'll watch
ads all day long.
And we're finding, we have
several ad partners in Russia
like Ad Colony does
really, really good
fill there and a few others.
And we're doing really
well on ads in Russia.
IAPs, so we try to be very fair.
We're not trying
to nickel and dime.
Our most popular
transaction in game
is a $4.99 transaction,
which you buy the game,
you don't see
anymore advertising
and you get a certain
amount of currency.
So our relationship with
players is very important.
We don't try to
monetize until you've
spent on a 15, 20
minutes in the game.
We want to know what
the game is about,
see the quality to
the work we've put in,
start to ask you, "Hey, are
you ready to spend some money?"
No.
And slowly it gets a
little more painful
until you've got to decide,
OK, I'm watching ads
or I'm going spend some money.
SHABIH RIZVI: Great.
Thank you.
Brendan, can you share
thoughts on monetizing music?
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL:
Yeah, for sure.
So we've some revenue
models in place already.
Just traditional
affiliate program.
So as people
discover tracks, they
can purchase them
through Soundwave.
And then we have deals in place
to get some of that rev share.
What we're really excited
about is-- we actually
have the unique position that
we are the only ones that
understand across all platforms,
all devices, all players,
and all apps what
somebody's listening to,
especially for native plays.
So if you listen to music
on the iPad or the iPhone
or the native music player
on your Android device,
we can actually track
all that as well.
And we're in a unique
position that we
can turn on the light
over the music industry
and let the music industry know
who's listening to what, where,
and when.
And that's an avenue that we're
kind of exploring right now,
just really allowing
the industry
to understand a lot of people
are listening to this artist
or a lot of people are listening
to this artist in this area
or at this time.
Really understand
trends as they emerge,
as opposed to six months
or a year after the fact
after they occur.
So we like to think
that we're replacing
the old model of sending
guys out on the street
to try and find new artists
and discover new guys by being
in every globe and
bar in the world
by having this app that's
actually in real time,
checking out what people
are listening to instead.
So for us going
forward, it's definitely
just that understanding
of what's being played.
SHABIH RIZVI: Awesome.
Fred, do you have thoughts
on maybe down the line?
But I'm sure you guys have
thought about it a little bit
and talked about it within--
FREDERIC DELLA
FAILLE: We obviously
are a venture-backed company
so they bet on the future.
We are 11 months old
so it's super early.
But what I know and what I see
is we have brands in the feed.
People are sharing
simple moments of life.
And so, we have
unique content and I
think that's something that's
like a good opportunity.
SHABIH RIZVI: Awesome.
I think we'll start to close
things out and give people
a chance to ask questions.
Two last questions.
One, what are some of
your favorite apps?
FREDERIC DELLA FAILLE: Sunrise.
The calendar app.
I really love this guy.
I love the app and they
just released on desktop.
So it makes.
Really nice.
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL:
For design purposes,
I definitely think
Flipboard and Pintrest are
two of my-- they're useful but
they're also really well built
on Android, for sure.
And designed really well.
So they're two that
we look to constantly.
MEL KIRK: I still
play a lot of games.
Ridiculous Fishing, if
you haven't seen that,
you got to play that.
And Monument Valley--
really, really great game.
Those two are--
still play those.
Ans Pitfall, the endless
runner from the classic days.
Yeah, definitely.
SHABIH RIZVI: Nice.
Cool.
So and then one last
question for everyone.
If there's folks in the
audience that new to Android,
new to Google Play, would
there be any one or two
bits of advice you'd
give them as they
consider building
on Android and Play.
MEL KIRK: I would say-- well,
from the game developer's
perspective, build
for the masses.
Build something
that a lot of people
are going to want to
play and something that
is easy to understand within
those first few moments.
And Google, the nice thing
about Google and Android
is that you guys are so open.
So I've never had a problem
getting a hold of anybody here.
So be persistent
and find somebody
to talk to because I'm sure
when you pique their interests,
they're definitely going
to help you out, so.
And I really appreciate
that about you guys.
So thank you very much.
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL: I'd say get
your [INAUDIBLE] business card.
FREDERIC DELLA FAILLE: No.
So I'm a designer and I was
super impressed by actually
engineers that understand
design on Android.
It's much more closer and
trusting your engineers
is-- I mean, that's a
big surprise for me.
SHABIH RIZVI: Great.
So questions for the panelists?
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
I'm wondering if any of
you guys are utilizing
in-app subscriptions and
I'm interested in what
price points are working for
you and what your churn rate is?
How many people have
successfully renew
subscriptions that have
bought it for the first month?
MEL KIRK: We haven't done
anything with subscriptions
yet.
We've thought about
it, especially
with our Pinball game, which
we're releasing content
for very frequently and
with a lot of branded,
like mass market type of
brands were people could just
play a monthly fee and know
that their new Pinball table is
going to show up x on x date.
The challenge is from a
development standpoint,
delivering the content
on time, every time.
As soon as you mess
that up, people
aren't going to trust you
and they're going to be mad.
So can you deliver the content?
I think that's what's holding
a company like ours back.
AUDIENCE: This is for Brendan.
Like how do you guys manage
the release schedule?
So we've been thinking
about having a beta channel
and we use it one way of
deploying it to a private beta
before we we were ready
to show it to the world.
And then we march the branch
back into the main channel.
How do you manage to make sure
that the releases are always
in sync and getting
out to the people?
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL: I mean
for us, it's pretty seamless.
I mean you just--
AUDIENCE: A weekly?
Or monthly?
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL: Oh, yeah.
So we change, right?
So when we started, we've been
out for just under a year,
right now.
And when we started,
we stayed awake
and pushed our new
updates every two weeks.
So we're just fast, fast,
fast iterations, little bugs
that we were finding.
Then when we hit our
groove, we slowed that down
and we started
waiting six weeks.
And we're in a four to
six week cycle right now.
For this current
cycle, we actually
haven't done a push in
a about three months
because there's a
huge release coming.
So for now, everybody's
just in on the beta
and giving feedback.
We changed our time
frames on that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
you said you didn't
use even a dime
to acquire users.
What do you think were the keys
that you used to acquire users
without even making an ad?
Or what did you do?
MEL KIRK: Well, I
would say there's
two different experiences
at this point.
One, on the Pinball
side, when you
have a license like
Star Wars or Marvel,
you work with them and
it's not like anything's
written in a contract.
We're going to do x, x, and
x for you for marketing.
But at the end of
the day, you're
going to work with
them on some level.
You get access to their
communities, their personality,
so there's a lot of marketing
that'll drive installs there.
But also, our PR
outreach is very good.
We're in touch with all the
editors from the big sites,
even just tech-focused sites.
They're constantly writing
about Zen Studios and our games.
And then recently,
on Castle Storm,
we cross promoted with
our existing users
on other-- on the Pinball side,
working with other developers.
And then working with guys
like, say for example, nVidia.
We support their
a higher end Tegra
and so we're on the front of
whatever it is they're doing.
We're working with Android and
getting featured placements.
And that's going to drive a ton.
If you get that,
that's the holy grail.
So all those different things
combined drive installs
and allows us to spend
money on different.
FREDERIC DELLA FAILLE:
For us as consumers,
it's really friends of
friends in real life.
So having the dealer focus
on the delight of the user,
making them happy,
using the product,
he's going to bring his friend.
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL: For us,
it's the product itself.
As people want to know what
their friends are listening to,
they'll share the
app to their friends
so that the whole thing is just
inherently viral in itself,
the way it's set up.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question about-- it's
related to piracy in that I've
uploaded apps to Google Play
and then they get
pirated and they're
on another app stores in
other countries within days.
Obviously, in-app purchases
don't work in those other app
stores and sometimes
the ads don't work.
So I'm just wondering
if you have any best
practices on how
you deal with that.
SHABIH RIZVI: So actually,
we talk on the side.
I don't think the
panelists will be
able to comment on
that, specifically.
That's totally fine.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So this
is related for you
guys who have thousands of
users in your beta program.
Do you have any concerns
with confidentiality?
Are you concerned
that people are
going to leak
screenshots of your app
out to the public ahead of time?
Is that a concern for you guys?
BRENDAN O'DRISCOLL:
We've been pretty open.
We've asked them not to do
it and they've not done it.
Yeah, so.
I don't know if it's
something that you'd
be worried about you'd
probably might have
to take particular precautions.
But for us, it's
always just been
we've been pretty trusting
with the community.
And no, I don't think there's
anything too sensitive
that we're working on anyway
that if it did happen,
we'd probably spin it in
a positive light anyway.
So not for us but
maybe for the others.
MEL KIRK: We
actually-- this sounds
funny-- we encourage
them to take screenshots
and then to share and to talk.
We went into beta when we
were ready for the game
to be out in the opening and
for everybody to see everything.
FREDERIC DELLA
FAILLE: And one thing
that we discovered in Asia
and particularly in Japan,
actually, they really
take screenshots and blog
about the updates, the beta.
And I think that's just
validation that what we do
is important for them.
But I guess it's also, how close
you are to the release date.
If no one can move as fast as
you do, doesn't really matter.
AUDIENCE: One last question.
You said that you use ads.
Do you use AdMob or
some other network
to promote ads, to get ads?
MEL KIRK: We're using
several networks.
And they each have the ability
to serve various markets.
So Ad Colony, I think everybody
here probably Ad Colony there.
They can serve
everywhere really well
and there's others that serve
more niche type of country
in smaller markets and
they're selling directly.
So they actually can
fill the ad call.
AdMob, massive reach
so we have several
implemented and
working with a lot.
SHABIH RIZVI: Cool.
We have time for one last
question if anyone has one?
All right, if not, then
thank you panelists.
And they'll still be around.